what else is going on out there I'm
trying to think of what happened I don't
even know dude I haven't been well they
have this beer the beer all this a lot
of stuff for Trans activism you know
shout out to them yeah and it's got to
be uh but what is it what is being trans
yeah I mean I know it's like
is it
I know it's men or women who want to be
the other right yeah or they feel stuck
inside of the they feel wrong fully
convicted yeah I think that's a good way
to put it convicted in the wrong body
right that's that that's what it seems
like to me anyway although some people
just want to go I'm neither I'm
non-binary you know
I'm throwing on some overalls I'm just
hanging out I'm getting honestly a
haircut a lot like yours
yeah yeah but I think Mullen is a pretty
nice non-binary
look yeah
do you think what do you think because
there's a lot of companies now that are
advertising stuff right I mean this is
hilarious Kid Rock it's just [__]
chill out Kid Rock okay Kid Rock but
he's also Kid Rock I know you know what
I'm like [__] Anheuser-Busch have a
terrific day well you really showed them
buying their [__] and shooting it with
guns and then basically giving them a
giving them an advertisement
like everyone who likes trans people is
going to be like damn Kid Rock's dumb
I'm gonna get some Bud Light
apparently grew up rich
he uh that's kind of wild grip at least
middle class yeah yeah his family had a
car dealership I think oh okay nice yeah
I think I think the thing about it I
think is that he's the place that he's
coming from is
do
Travis are they trying like
what is I just wonder what is the biz
what is is there a business goal of it
does it seem
that's what I'm just curious about it
because it seems like an interesting
move yeah yeah yeah that's the thing
that's what I think has kind of been
blown kind of crazily out of proportion
is like
trans people that I know they just want
to be trans right they don't they just
want to like not be like kill like
because that's the thing as a if you're
like going M to like M to F if you were
like born a man you transition to female
it's like that's like a lot of them like
become sex workers a lot of them like
get like violence against them the guys
who feel like they've been either
tricked or like whatever and it's like
it's like a pretty scary thing to you
know it's a pretty like tough lifestyle
and they're just like hey I just want
like not to be killed and to be like
basically respected and to be able to go
to like the doctor and I just don't it's
such a low percentage of people too
that's what's crazy to me that we're
having this discussion that's the part
to me is interesting it's such a small
and I wonder are you helping trans
people buy like Bud Light like is this
the move to help
because I I totally understand what
you're saying like imagine if you are if
you feel that way right imagine if you
really feel it right yeah now I think
there's a big there could be a
difference between people who really
feel it and also now if they're
commercializing it or if they're
sensationalizing it so much that a mind
that isn't sure now adapts to it to like
have a cause because people will can
grasp onto a lot of causes right for
sure and I think like
I think like with any kind of thing that
gets a lot of publicity you will have
people that are like
just unsure will like reach on to it and
you will have here's the thing with
anything that gets any traction you'll
get people doing it cynically to get
famous right right but the way that
there's like it's like a one percentage
of people are trans
point zero zero one of them are like
these weird people doing it for
attention right you know so it's like
that's what it's crazy about these
discussions it's like for the most part
what we're talking about is like let
people have jobs you know like just let
them have basic and the way I look at it
right is like just let them go about
their lives without facing
discrimination and like who gives a [__]
yeah what do you care if somebody like
was born a guy wants to chop their dick
off and be a girl yeah why does that
bother you and I do find it a little
ironic where it's like especially people
that are talking about like you know
like
not to get super political with it but
it's like the states that are very anti
the trans [__] it's like you have people
talking about how they want limited
government but then they're like oh I
have to check your daughters to see if
your daughter has a vagina before like
Florida was talking about a bill where
they're tracking girls periods to prove
their their to prove their biological
female it's like like a white bracelet
or something yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah a loop strap Florida yeah Ron
DeSantis wanted one around like teams
inside of them and it's like aren't you
supposed to be the one for like limited
government but we're checking girls
period it's just like or they made it
like illegal to mention the period it's
like dude it's [__] crazy and I'm
just like I don't get like I have
something I don't understand why it's a
like if someone's trans let them be
trans like I would never be upset at
anybody that's trans or like I would be
very curious what it's really like for
sure I would be very curious in today's
world what if someone is like just gay
and they see an option to be for a clout
or just totally uh straight and season
it because there's such a me it's such a
like yeah like you know a currency out
there now that I could see that being
some but I don't say that to diminish it
because those people are also
diminishing if people are really dealing
with that like for sure I don't know I
guess I guess I just wonder is this the
best person to introduce that
to the world like because a lot of
people now are just starting to talk
about trans which is maybe is good but
it's also such a small percentage of
people I guess I just don't understand
well is this going to be helpful to
trans people because it almost
like if I'm a trans person right and my
life is tough right yeah if I really am
if I because I believe that you know I
mean you makes God makes so many cookies
man you could yeah yeah yeah yeah
something or nature could be also
merging you don't know yeah and I also
think in like other societies like
ancient ones people were kind of like in
between genders and other sites had like
multiple genders yeah look at Robin Hood
yes
those guys were in Tights come on you
tell me you know somebody somebody threw
on made Marion's dress Big John he was a
bear dude yeah
big backlash against trans people
because I think it's become a
conservative Boogeyman where they're
talking about like you know drag queens
and they're talking about how drag
queens are gonna like groom your like
they're calling gay people groomers and
[__] and I think that's really dangerous
and I think that attention has come
because trans people are being used as a
political tool in the negative whereas
like I mean dude
it's so funny to hear people talk about
how drag queens are like you know oh
they're so dangerous for kids where it's
like drag queen like you think they
molest P like politicians and Priests
are up two million kids to zero on yeah
that's the drag queens it's like you
know maybe a thousand maybe like a
thousand yeah yeah maybe there's one
yeah there's one of them whatever but
it's like still drag queens are gonna
start having to do like flea flickers
and like trick plays to get back in the
game yeah
compared to politics they're the ones
[__] kids and it's like it's just
become this political Ploy you know yeah
it's like yeah that's it I mean look
that's a that's a really great Point man
I think what I hear a lot of times that
people are scared of especially on the
backs of like the vaccine and stuff like
that people are scared that
well is this some another reach where
they're trying to where the media will
then use like a lot of like film
television exposure about gender
uncertainty and then to start to get you
young people to want to take like a
gender blocker right or some type of a
medicine right and I don't know enough
about the medicine yeah yeah but I think
as when I look even how influenced I was
I mean I watched WWE wrestling yeah if
the rock cut his dick off you'd be
thinking about it dude if somebody threw
my grandmother against the if somebody
just threw my grandmother against the
ropes yeah I would have kicked that
bitch's head off
that's how influenced I was by WWE yeah
absolutely it was over bro no amount of
calcium pills was gonna bring her back
yeah so I think that's a lot of people's
fear it's like man there's so much
influence over my children that
if they start to use this chip are they
then just going to come in with another
medicine on the back of covid where a
lot of people are skeptical about the
vaccine now sure and rightfully so yeah
so I think that's probably a lot of I
think that's a lot of the fear yeah but
but I think the the molestation part
you're right it's like yeah it's like oh
you can't molest my kids I'll let them
you know it's only going to be done by
my own Yeah by my preacher yeah yeah
yeah yeah not a guy with lipstick which
again it's not like I do think I just
don't think I just don't I'm not
convinced that the numbers are that big
where it's like all of a sudden all
these kids are transitioning because
they think it's cool I think it's so
hard to do that like people would say
that about like uh in like sports right
or like Leah Thompson they were talking
about that swimmer yeah who like was
trans then was like a much better
swimmer as a woman than than she was as
a man
the idea that you would cut your dick
off to win [__] College swimming
do you really want to you really want
that bronze medal in College swimming
that bad that you're going to chop your
nuts off it's like I don't know that's
like and then have people like you'd
swim faster without you yeah that's
might be weighing you down sure you're a
seal but it's just like I guess I'm not
convinced that like I think a lot of
this [__] is just fear-mongering for no
reason yeah and especially when you see
the statistics like I saw some poll I
don't know I don't know if like we can
find it but it was like there's like a
pull of [__] of like the percentage
people thought a bunch of things not
just trans but like a ton of stuff like
right how many people are a Muslim in
America how many people are like get
whatever and everyone overestimated
everything and that like I think I
literally think Tran like a percentage
of trans people America is like like one
percent I think we looked at the other
day it was 1.7 million about five
percent young adults in US say their
gender is different from their taxonomic
see now this article sounds so
delusional to me right yeah five percent
of Youth it could be now that could be
they asked a hundred youths in Brooklyn
yeah outside you know but that that's
the thing about articles you just don't
know but that kind of percentage Yeah
you see that it could definitely make
people think what's going on and then
you get yeah you get scared why else is
so scary man I also think there's a
difference between like fully
transitioning and being like hey I do
think there's a lot of kids who are like
hey maybe I'm non-binary yeah I'm like
I'm not going to change anything
medically but like maybe I'm gonna start
instead of being called Eric my name is
now sock yeah and I'm half a guy you
know what I mean like like it is there
is like there is some change in that I
think definitely I think I have more
like young friends who are like maybe it
open to experimenting with gender in
that they think you know the way every
generation has different radical ideas
to older people and I think that's
another thing I try and think about is
like you don't want to be the old guy
who's like well that's not right that's
not how I had it yeah you know what I
mean like the part of me is like I defer
to young people sometimes a little bit
when it's like and some of this like
people are going to find themselves and
they're gonna like settle down and it's
like whatever they might those
percentages might like drop or whatever
but it's just like I think this [__] is
kind of like fluid and like always
changing but ultimately I don't think
it's dangerous like that's the thing
it's like who gives a [__] if somebody
wants to change their name or like be
perceived as something else I don't
understand why you [__] care yeah oh
I don't I don't think I feel like a lot
of people probably don't yeah yeah but I
think if it came to a point where then a
kid could go get say If I'm 14 right
yeah sure and I don't know how I'm
feeling right yeah maybe I'm gay maybe
I'm straight maybe uh women just don't
like me bro I mean there was times when
I was younger when I thought that women
didn't like me enough that I thought
maybe I'm supposed to like men dude me
too I was like I was like maybe I'll
just I was like there must be something
wrong with me yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah yeah that maybe in my head somehow
I'm messed up I'm not messed up but I am
I'm just not seeing things clearly yeah
you know and I'm sure no I'm with you
there so say if you're going through
that and then you decide to that's where
it's like I just don't like it when
there's possibility for the drugs to get
involved that's the part for me that's
like
man I don't know because I got on
antidepressants at a young age and I
can't get off of them yeah yeah you know
so I don't know it's it's definitely
interesting and I think look we've had
some good thoughts about it you know and
some good like discussion about it and I
will say just from uh like I've hooked
up with some people who are they them
non-binary I've gotten some excellent
they then [__] damn really yeah yeah
absolutely wow brother no joke I'm the
best head I've gotten is a tie between
two they them wow people it was awesome
damn yeah probably traditionally appear
though you know they they if you saw
them you'd probably have that leap year
you know what I mean but still yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so shout out to you know
they them [__] is very powerful and
it's out there the Lord's leap year
look a lot of like Asian people I think
are have a or uh are against this sort
of thing they're very like gender yeah
you know you samurai or ninja yeah
they're even starting to name their kids
I think like
him him was one of them
he's like nobody's confusing my son I
just feel like it's such a sensitive
topic for whoever's really going through
that yeah yeah that I don't know if it's
the right thing for a company to come
along
I don't know see you know what I'm
saying I don't know what you say like or
what I'm I'm questioning I just I don't
know you're supposed to feel that out I
understand the question I think like
pause I think anything that kind of
normalizes a struggle that somebody's
going through is fine you know it's like
okay like I see what you're saying where
it's like it brings attention to it and
the negative attention to me is a
problem but it's like it's on the people
who are negative about it like you know
I'm obviously very like I just don't
I think the real problems are the
legislative is the legislative stuff
that's happening against trans people
personally yeah where it's like it's
making their lives difficult it's making
some people not be able to get like
medical care it's you know well
insurance will make find any reason not
to give you anything well that's the
other thing it's like yeah that's
another problem with our country where
it's like so many of our biggest
problems come down to we don't have our
Basics covered in the richest country in
the history of the world which is so
[__] up like no one should be [__]
well it's not profitable it's not you
know yeah it comes down to a bottom line
you start to feel like a you know you
start to feel like a pawn I think that's
I think that's another thing it's such a
time where everything that the media
does feels like someone is being pawned
that I think that just the everything
these days I feel like kind of makes me
a little bit nervous yeah you know I I'm
with you too I am a little I'm like
What's the shell game here yeah yeah
yeah I'm a little pessimistic about the
course we're on in general just because
of like you know global warming [__] but
also like inequality in America is so
crazy where it's like yeah dude and I
think a lot of the anger that you see in
general like even like even for some
people trans has become like a boogeyman
and it's like they're angry because yeah
their family member has [__] cancer
insurance doesn't cover it their job has
been you know their job is gone there's
no [__] you know a train gets
derailed no one's [__] cleaning it up
now they have [__] poison in their in
their water and it's like these are all
things that could be covered with like
if we held our government accountable
and they just like we had to they had to
provide basic needs for people yeah but
everything is gone kind of to [__] and
it's like it's easy to start disagreeing
about the stuff that does not matter
when you're just so angry because you
feel like you're getting sued because we
are getting screwed but we're getting
screwed by in my opinion big
corporations by everyone who's just like
gobbling up all the money and making
sure that it's like you know wait you
know wages having place with inflation
you know minimum wage if it was like
what it was in the 70s now it should be
like you know like 40 bucks an hour or
something you know what I mean like
I think that's the root of all like our
disagreements on all our all the anger
here and I think
oh yeah when people don't feel like
they're not belonged to yeah like
they're taken care of you want to feel
like you also well at the same time that
you're kicking down the traditions of
the country yeah you know and at the
same time that you're taking you're
taking away like or you're making it
harder I think I don't know it's a lot
there's a lot of stuff I'm not trying to
not talk think about it it's just a lot
I don't know anybody
that is trans and a lot of my friends
don't you know and I'm even in La five
months out yeah yeah yeah I have some
friends oh wait we have one we had a
guest Robin
Robin Tran Robin Tran I believe so yeah
and that is a little on the nose I mean
yeah
but Robin Tran is a comedian and I don't
know she didn't have the surgery at that
time okay
um
uh
and then Joe Dash
was a male comedian and he has
um I don't know Robin personally yeah
j-o-e-d-o-s-c-h
Fifi now is his name and he got a
transition okay
I believe I don't want to talk out of
pocket he's Joe Joe's one of the most is
one of the uh
smartest and uh
just really Mo it was really a
captivating yeah um I don't know him as
much as a woman and I don't think it's I
don't know if there's a difference
between knowing someone when they are a
man or a woman because dude that's a
journey
well that's the thing I remember when
the first time we went to Florida when I
was a kid and I was like this is gonna
be crazy
yeah but imagine every cell in your body
in your life yeah you know what I'm
saying we're going to San France yeah oh
yeah we're going to San Francisco
brother or we're going to like yeah
Brooklyn you know yeah yeah uh yeah I
mean I think there's probably some you
probably just feel more I would just
guess you'd feel more comfortable you'd
probably feel like more yourself you
know I can't speak I can't speak to
being trans whatever but
um
you know I'm sure you just like maybe
even more pleasant to be around because
it's like anything imagine like hiding
something and then be and also it's like
a hard thing like a lot of people don't
understand it a lot of people are can be
like probably in your fam like coming
out as gay is hard enough imagine being
like numb to you to like somebody who
would have a problem with being gay it's
like coming out as five times gay you
know what I mean like going yeah I'm
like a girl yeah I'm so gay I'm a girl
like that's what that's what like a you
know like a like I'm chasing my hotel
yeah like you're like you're like the
Ultimate Warrior of gays
like bring up when the Ultimate Warrior
came in the ring
there was nothing like that brother dude
it was electric yeah there was yeah when
that happened that changed the scene
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one